les insectes sont en déclin partout dans
le monde c'est ce que révèle une étude
britannique publiée dans la revue nature
en 30 ans la population des insectes a
chuté de 50% à certains endroits
principalement dans les régions
tropicales sur simplement une preuve de
plus
celle-ci globale qui confirme la
tendance lors de l'effondrement de la
biodiversité en entomologie club depuis
les années 90 au banc des accusés les
changements climatiques et l'agriculture
intensive
le phénomène est observé aussi au canada
mais il est difficile d'avoir un
portrait exact de la situation
il existe très peu de données
disponibles ça veut pas dire pour nos
peaux d'espèces menacées mais c'est vrai
que ce qu'on observe dans les dernières
années un rapport avec le changement
climatique c'est tout les verts c'est
qu'on voit des espèces arrivée du sud
dans deux pays c'est pas des espèces qui
sont problématiques que la population
mondiale va monter plus on va avoir
besoin de zones agricoles et puis en
bois zones agricoles mais plus hard rain
et initiaux population des sexes cercle
est vicieux s'ajoute à l'équation
certaines maladies que les insectes
peuvent développer en estrie certains
apiculteurs ont perdu 70% de leurs
abeilles le mapaq a ouvert une enquête
l'hypothèse d'un parasite virale
pourrait en être la cause les grands
problèmes sociaux cette année avec les
abeilles on à paul puis nous aurons
dépend des sols et les abeilles qui
fondent les les gros travail en fait le
fait qu il faut mettre les chances de
notre côté puis à augmenter la
biodiversité
tout le dossier des abeilles qu'on n'a
pas au pardon on apprenait encore ce
matin mais ça c'est quelque chose qui
est très préoccupante le mapaq a
d'ailleurs lancé en octobre 2021 le
réseau québécois on recherche en
agriculture durable un projet mobilisant
plus de 200 chercheurs au ministère l'on
a lancé des recherches surtout
inquiétant parce qu'on sait quel point
les pollinisateurs les parieurs
importance est vitale pour notre
industrie bioalimentaire alors de huy
une préoccupation il existe près de 25
mille espèces d'insectes au québec et
même si aucun n'est réellement en danger
d'extinction l'urgence d'agir pour
protéger notre biodiversité est bien
réel ici marie michel lauzon radio
canada montréal